Find the reciprocal
of 2 and 4/5.
So if we want to invert this
fraction, we have to write it
as a pure fraction first, or
as an improper fraction.
Right now, it's just
a mixed number.
So let's just write it as
an improper fraction.
So 2 and 4/5, if we write it as
an improper fraction, it's
still going to be over 5, but
the numerator is now going to
be 5 times 2 plus 4, and that's
because 2 is 10/5, or 2
times 5 fifths.
So let's write it like that.
So it's going to be
2 times 5 plus 4.
2 times 5 is 10.
10/5 is the same thing as 2, and
then the 4/5 is this 4/5
right there.
So this is going to be equal
to 2 times 5 is 10
plus 4 is 14: 14/5.
So these are equivalent
fractions.
This is written as
a mixed number.
This is written as an
improper fraction.
It's improper because the
numerator is bigger than the
denominator.
Now we want to find
the reciprocal.
When you find the reciprocal,
you just switch the numerator
and the denominator.
You just flip the fraction.
So if you want to take the
reciprocal-- let me do this in
a new color.
If we want to take the
reciprocal of this, we just
swap the 5 and the 14.
So this is going to be--
instead of 14/5,
it's going to be 5/14.
And we're done!